Victoria is in Hawaii hi Victoria
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hello
thank you for taking my call
sure what's up so my husband and I are
in a solar con solar lease contract and
we're having some issues because the
trying to sell our house we've had seven
authors back that we've come out of
escrow twice for house because of the
solar contract we were told before we
find the contracts that if we were to
sell our house when the new buyers would
be able to renegotiate their contract
and if they didn't want to then the
company was a loser panel or we could
take the panel's with us to wherever
we're meeting likes or we could buy the
panel's out those are our three options
while we're both active to you know to
me and moving to Texas in July okay so
they told you all of those things is any
of that not in the actual contract no
it's not okay so it didn't only what
does the contract actually say you just
owe a mossad amount of money right yeah
the option trailer contract was a
ballooning payment over the next 20
years or exception and we're sort of
fell off a little bit higher but not
changed my payoff amount has to pay them
off
so the their early buyout option isn't
an option until six years into your
contract the option that they're giving
us right now so buyout is $70,000 the
system itself if you were to get by one
outright brand-new it's only $25,000 so
you did a release you say you did a
lease honest yes we don't know jeez okay
miss the option that they're giving us
about right now is what the contract is
worth for the investors which is about
seventy eight thousand dollars okay just
can can you not pay it off as a part of
the sale of the house no we cannot do
that at seventy eight thousand dollars
and we won't be making that much money
on the house how much will you be making
on the house you're looking at about
$40,000 profit yeah
with the solar panels on the house if we
can get somebody to take their current
content no no no no no no no no no I'm
just saying if you leave the solar
panels on the house the house is only
worth enough to put $40,000 in your
pocket that is correct and that's with
paying the solar company nothing correct
okay you need a lawyer you need a lawyer
and you know you're probably gonna give
your $40,000 of equity to the solar
company to settle the contract and leave
the solar panels on the house and walk
away you lost your equity when you did
this deal okay now if you can get them
to take 40,000 to settle on the 78 today
my god you must have covered the whole
house and solar panels we did in Hawaii
we were paying $600 a month and our
electricity with yeah it's still a
really really bad idea to do this I mean
the only time solar panels work is if
you pay cash for them and they do work
if you pay cash for them but never ever
finance them and triple never lease them
because of this exact situation right
here
yeah and never believe anything is is a
part of the deal if it's not in the
contract yeah we've got an old attorney
friend of mine that says if it's not in
the contrary if it's not in writing it
didn't happen and that's what you're
discovering here that you had a slime
ball at your kitchen table telling you
is what the deal was one thing when it
wasn't it was something else and we know
he's a slimeball cause he lied that's
the point
you have very clear you know belief of
this I mean if you have any of the old
sales materials that indicate that the
contract should say that your attorney
could use that as a part of the
negotiating process and go we're getting
ready sue you
because you're just a bunch of slimy
people my god $78,000 where the solar
panels you wouldn't break even on that
oh that's awful that's really awful Hey
we we believe in solar around here there
are certain areas of the country that it
breaks even but if you need a break even
on those things and you know four or
five years you don't need a 15-year
break even on solar panels it then you
don't die you don't buy anything that
does that
meaning you save enough on electricity
to pay to give you the cash that you
paid for the solar panel back within
five years and if you don't do that you
don't need to do the deal they're not
efficient enough in the area that you're
in with your particular situation with
the cost electricity in your situation
to do that and then you don't get caught
up in what Victoria's in Victoria gets
you a lawyer